[Music]
your co-star son William Scott Seann was
here yeah he's on the show of the day
and he of course you know he's made
Stifler an iconic character yep in the
movies and then I was talking to him and
he said that actually you are the most
like Stifler in real life right which I
find very hard to believe because your
character is is so mild-mannered and
then I can't believe that you're a perv
well okay to be clear I'm not a perv I
think what he means I hope what he means
is that I tend to do things that are a
bit shocking and maybe seem a bit out of
character for me I tend to you know go
to sort of darker place and say things
that people wouldn't expect you know me
to say or anyone to say for that matter
I thought that would be the case I think
maybe that's the comparison he's a perv
I think is that no no I got it so then I
saw you you twit you sent out a tweet
not long ago that said that you were
getting rid of your stripper pole oh
right yeah yeah yeah well I was a
stripper pole in their home well I did
my I came home one day and my wife had
gotten a stripper pole that she wanted
me to install in our living room which
is how it comes it's like the IKEA like
one of these I think it was I think it
was maybe the Hoffman cooze version but
you know that's funny on a lot of levels
one that she wanted a stripper pole in
our living room and two that she thought
that I would actually put it together
and do any kind of work at all but yeah
so anyway she we compromised because I
was like we're not putting this in the
living room we're not having a stream
this is ridiculous and she's like why
you know we compromise we put it in a
guest bedroom which at the time was
jenny was sword my wife was sort of
using it as like her little meditation
room we called it the Zen den right and
we put up this stripper pole again not
me but I think we paid somebody and then
um so then it became the champagne room
and and you have this little stripper
room in
in your house yeah yeah and then
eventually this will be the the kids
room when we have a kid so I think
that's I think that's a perfect and
natural progression of what they're
going to be yeah it's a love it do you
love it no we have people used to come
over it used to be so much fun cone and
people would come over they bring their
kids they dance on it they I would get
on it I would Purell it first from top
to bottom but I would I would get on
there and it'll be fun one day to tell
you know being there with my son or
daughter and be like you know this is
this is where mommy used to dance for
daddy's dollars you know story danced
for Daddy's dog yeah I think it'll be
sweet you know so it's gone now alright
the pole is it is yes she um finally
gave it I mean it was literally right in
the middle of the room and by the way we
would still have guests over you know I
mean my parents would come and stay with
us and they'd be in there because there
was also a bed right in the room
how convenient and convenien actually
but yeah so my you know my parents being
here on the be a stripper pole right
next to them maybe they ever try it out
like it's just pretty guys I would
rather you not sure if my parents were
using a pole Snoop Dogg coming from
their own